today at book TV org markdown recounts
the history of US immigration laws and
incidents of abuse in his new book
American gulag this talk from politics
and prose bookstore in Washington DC
lasts about an hour good evening
everyone and welcome to politics and
prose I'm like Jarrett on oh and for the
the owners here the staff here I'd like
to thank you for coming out tonight it's
a real pleasure to welcome mark Dow here
he will be up here and speak for he will
speak for about 20 25 minutes and then
we will have about the same time for
questions and answers for which we ask
that you use the audience mic right here
it just is it keeps the talk audible
which is is good for also mark dad will
speak on his book American gulag
although it offers context to the
national discussion on immigration
prison systems abuse and human rights
that have been ongoing that has been
ongoing since September of 11 and the
Iraq war the subject of immigration
prisons in the United States remains
largely under exposed meaning the
contribution of this book cannot be
overstated as horrific and insight as it
may be a freelance writer and poet
co-editor of machinery of death the
reality of America's death penalty
regime author of American gulag archdale
thanks Mike and thanks Cleve and I want
to thank politics and prose for having
me thanks for coming this is a book
about immigration detention centers and
so I'm going to say a couple of very
brief things just so you know what an
immigration detention center is and why
this book exists and then I'm going to
talk a little and read a short passage
and talk a little and read a short
passage and then you can ask me
questions and heckle man well you can
have come any time along the way
actually the the immigration detention
system is run by the Immigration Service
what used to be called the AI NS is now
the immigration and customs enforcement
of the Department of Homeland Security
the people who are in this detention
system are quote unquote administrative
detainees they range from we'll get into
later get into who these people are but
they can range from asylum seekers to
people who have overstayed their visas
to people who have committed crimes and
thus lost their legal status to people
who are being detained indefinitely
because no country will take them back
twenty-three thousand of these prisoners
ten years ago there were five to six
thousand i ns prisoners let me clarify
right away because of the terminology
officially these people are detainees
they're being detained by the
Immigration Service but as a small
contribution to cleansing us of some
kind of bureaucratic rhetoric I call
them prisoners because that's what they
are they're held sometimes in
immigration detention centers sometimes
in federal penitentiaries
often in local jails and private prisons
scattered around the country they wear
prison uniforms they share cells with
sentenced inmates and again these are
people who are not serving time even if
they had criminal convictions they've
either served their time or in many
cases their convictions were so minor
that they were not actually sentenced to
time and yet under the very repressive
1996 immigration laws there now subject
to deportation just to pick kind of a
random example so you know what I'm
talking about when I talk about a
someone who is serving time for a minor
crime someone who was here legally with
a green card but never became a US
citizen may be committed shoplifting
problem may be a one-time drug offense
many years back in the meantime has
successfully run a business has US
citizen wife and children that kind of
person under the 1996 immigration laws
can be deported I was recently in
contact with a man in just that
situation from Portugal who came to the
United States at the age of 2 legally
with his parents and in his late 30s
because of a one-time drug conviction
was served his sentence and then was
detained by the Immigration Service for
five years then deported to Portugal so
when we hear talk about illegal
immigration and so-called criminal
aliens we're often I would even say
usually not talking about the kind of
people that that the folks who like to
use the term criminal alien are trying
to have you imagine I'll just say
briefly how I came to write this book
because a lot of people wonder
in the early 1990s i was living in miami
and was looking for a job teaching in a
prison i had done some teaching in
prisons before and got a job teaching
high school equivalency classes in
immigration detention center um and
another teacher and I were fired we I
was not working for the Immigration
Service I was a contract employee
working for the school system but the
Immigration Service pressured the school
system into firing another teacher me
when we made complaints about some
mistreatment of prisoners just to give
you an idea just by telling you what my
complaint was and what her complaint was
you get an idea of kind of the spectrum
of mistreatment that goes on in these
facilities what I complained about I
hardly considered it a complaint I was
just going to resolve a little problem
because I had a student a young Haitian
man who was upset because all of his
paperwork that he had brought with him
on a boat from Haiti he was seeking
political asylum is his legal documents
is address book with relatives in the
United States his Bible his
french-english dictionary had all been
confiscated in a in a late-night
crackdown by the correctional officers
detention guards at the chrome detention
center for for no very clear reason that
the stated reason was that there was
going to be a demonstration outside the
camp and administration was concerned
the prisoners would set things on fire
it was never really clear why this kid
would set the few possessions he had in
the world on fire but in not only were
they confiscated but what I soon found
out was that the the official in charge
of chrome tried to make me feel better
by saying well first of all the detainee
the detainees belongings weren't just
confiscated they were destroyed
but it wasn't just your student who was
singled out this was done to all of the
prisoners and again it's the reason I'm
telling you this is to try to convey the
the kind of real isolation netherworld
that these people are put into they
they're not serving sentences and they
don't need to be treated as prisoners
and yet they are at every level that
there are pictures from 20 years ago the
early days of the chrome detention
center and it was a harsh place but the
photos are striking because the inmates
are wearing their own clothes and if you
just imagine imagine someone who you
know very well or better yet imagine
someone who you don't know what it's
look around that someone in this room
who you don't know and imagine how you
might judge that person differently if
they were wearing a prison uniform
instead of whatever they were wearing
now it's it's not a trivial thing
because people who really don't need to
be treated as prisoners are made into
inmates or prisoners and once once that
takes place all kinds of things can
happen as we've seen in a lot of
different contexts I mentioned the
spectrum of abuses the the other teacher
knew she was making some dramatic
allegations because she went to the
Miami Herald and said that she finally
felt it was her duty to talk about the
fact that for years she had been hearing
the guards were pressuring female
inmates female detainees into exchanging
sexual favors for promises of release
from detention this gives you some idea
of the of the spectrum these things have
been going on in immigration detention
centers for more than two decades and
there are reams of documentation about
it and for all sorts of reasons these
are not victims who the administration
and and any administration is going to
spend any political capital defending
because there's too much political
capital in dehumanizing them
that's really all I want to say about
immigration policy this is a book about
immigration prisons but I like to think
it's really a book about a certain
prison culture and just for
clarification let me say that these
immigration detainees are held today I
already say this the facilities that
they're held in local jails all around
the country detention centers federal
penitentiaries private prisons so
they're often with sentence inmates
one of the things that happened during
my research I originally had an idea for
this book just being a collection of
letters that I NS detainees or prisoners
right because there are a lot of them
out there they and eventually the the
book evolved a number of times but at
some point I realized that if I was
really going to be able to at some point
I realized I really needed to talk to
some guards and it wasn't easy because
they tended not to want to talk to me
but a really interesting thing began to
emerge for me which is that I I realized
there was this situation where there
were really no good guys and bad guys
even though there were people who were
clearly victims of the system so I'm
going to read you now a couple of pages
from an interview with a man named
Richard Franklin who was a
african-american correctional officer in
oakdale Louisiana which is a prison run
by the Bureau of Prisons together with
the Immigration Service and he has just
described the heat Richard worked for
the Bureau of Prisons but because of the
way the prison is run he regularly
watched I NS officials dealing with the
immigration detainees or inmates and he
describes a few of them as or he told me
that they described themselves as the I
NS ass kickers the first time that
Richard Franklin saw the inas ass
kickers at work the inmate was Jamaican
Franklin was working the computer in
receiving and discharge logging in the
new arrivals the usual processing was in
progress inmates being moved in
fingerprinting mug shots property
storage a new detainee wanted his box of
property so that he could count the
money he had come in with and make a
note of it the guy just wanted his
property that's all he was asking for
Franklin recalls the Jamaican had good
reason to want to count his money
Franklin opens one of the binders he
brought stacks of binders with his own
paperwork to our interview I have some
paperwork here where a guy worked hand
in hand with me he says he is referring
to a fellow officer who joins us but
prefers anonymity he gave me all this
paperwork off different inmates well
staff members stole these inmates money
the money that they were being deported
with and I got some of the amounts here
he hands me a single space document
maybe a dozen pages inmates names and
their alien registration numbers
alongside dollar amounts left behind in
their accounts after deportation and in
his friends handwriting seven hundred
dollars was stole five hundred and
twenty four dollars 311 dollars 731
dollars the Jamaican didn't get to count
his money Franklin says two of the IAS
officers picked him up and slammed him
to the floor head first when they did
that the other two officers walked in
for my ness and they started kicking him
and punching him and telling him he
wasn't going to get nothing and cursing
him out I can remember the inmate I was
sitting in the computer room with the
door open they were about from here from
where i'm sitting now to that wall he
gestures beyond his friend perched on
the edge of the motel bed to the wall
about 15 feet away I can remember the
inmate telling me young brother you go
until are you going to let them do me
like this are you going to let them do
me like this and one of the IAS officers
punched him in the stomach they locked
him in the cell they never took the
cuffs or the shackles off him off him
and they laughed
that detail without the cuffs and the
shackles matters matters to correctional
officer Franklin because it tells him
something about the agents not only will
they brutally beat a man without reason
but they will violate procedure to do it
typically after dropping off prisoners
with the Bureau of Prisons INF agents
would take their chains with them but in
this case the AI NS agents left the
Jamaican man in AI NS chains in the
Bureau of Prisons processing area
Franklin these are their shackles and
chains they left soon enough however
they returned memos in hand they already
had two other Bureau of Prisons
employees to side with the story
Franklin says then they wanted me to go
along with it I was the only left out
one I told them no I'm not signing that
I'm not going to go along with that that
didn't happen like that he wrote up his
own version of the incident and that's
when I started getting you not a team
player whose side are you on you know
these [ __ ] inmates who care about
them you hear that all the time from I
NS and the Bureau of Prisons they work
hand in hand if it's to do an inmate in
he's going to get done in
and I just want to add something else
that Franklin says because I have to say
that I was interviewing this man this
guard down in Louisiana and we met in
this motel room and then the next day at
his home and he had these stacks of his
own paperwork and it was just stunning
to me he didn't really have he had his
own anti-discrimination suit going
against the Bureau of Prisons because
eventually there was retaliation what he
alleges was retaliation against him i
think his case might actually still be
pending but what he was saying about i
ns treatment of detainees was not that
directly related to his case in other
words there was no reason for for him to
be telling me all this stuff except well
you can judge for yourself the reasons
but i just want to quote a final thing
he says because i think at a time when a
lot of people are asking themselves how
certain things can happen in a prison
there are basic things that happen in
prisons all the time just because of the
way prisons are run Franklin says look
these inmates are done in no respect
your manhood is taken away when you
locked behind them doors and that's just
it you're not considered a man to them
if you're not wearing the green I NS
uniform or the white and gray Bureau of
Prisons uniform you're not considered a
man you're considered some of the scum
of the earth you're a criminal and
that's just it
along the way talking to two
correctional officers talking to
correctional officers one of the more
interesting things that happen is i
began to find out that correctional
officers were some of the most
articulate and insightful critics of the
Immigration Service the I talked to lots
of prisoners lots of detainees I talked
to some immigration officials often to
their public affairs people to lots of
advocates and non-governmental
organizations but what was really
intriguing to me is to find that a lot
of the people actually running the
jail's that were contracting with the
feds to houses is inmates because this
is a major source of revenue for local
jails around the country and the people
running these places with in many cases
would say to me we don't necessarily
think these people should be locked up
but that's not our decision I want to
say just I'm going to read a brief
section about a mari el Cuban prisoner
so I want to speak for just a minute to
say who these Mario Cuban prisoners are
and then and then after that we'll open
it up
I'm the Mario boat lift and everything
that came after it's the subject already
of a couple of books and at least one
other one that's in the making that I
know of so we'll just scratch the
surface here but in 1980 Castro allowed
Cubans to leave the island and over a
six-month period as some of you will
remember 125,000 Cubans came to the
United States to South Florida at first
now they live in a lot of different
places the great majority of them as the
ANS itself has said or have assimilated
are law-abiding people because of a
strange technicality in immigration law
a Mario Cuban who commits a crime or
technically doesn't even need to commit
a crime the ANS could decide to take a
Mario Cuban into custody into I NS
detention and because that person cannot
be deported because the reason that
Immigration Service has the authority to
detain someone is to deport them or to
make sure they show for proceedings so
what happens if that person cannot be
deported what happens if that person's
country won't take them back well
actually in 2001 the Supreme Court
answered that question and in a decision
called zat vitus vs davis said there's
in general just a six-month limit on how
long you can detain someone and then if
it doesn't look like you can deport them
you release them and then subsequently
if you're able to arrange deportation
then you could pick them up and deport
them which is exactly what has happened
two Cambodians who at one time we
couldn't deport and now can but for for
fairly esoteric legal reasons the United
States government says that that Supreme
Court decision does not apply to the
Mario Cubans because they came here with
a kind of special permission and so they
haven't really entered the country and I
know it's it's it's difficult to
to get your mind around this but it's
something called the entry fiction and
it means that even though they've been
here for a quarter of a century now and
have connections and have family here of
pay taxes none of that matters according
to the law there at the border asking to
be let in and it sounds bizarre and
maybe not even that interesting but the
reason it matters is because one of the
implications is that they're not
entitled to due process and so the US
government says that it has the
authority to detain them year after year
after year after year after year a man
that I've been in touch with recently
who lives in California served two years
on criminal conviction in the mid 80s
and he recently got out after being
detained by the AI NS for 20 years this
is something it's it's just still
astonishing to me and with all of the
debate about civil liberties in this
country the plight of the Mario Cubans
here just is remains off off the map
unfortunately I visited a jail in Lake
Charles Louisiana where number of these
mari el Cubans were being held and it
was one of these places where the
jailers were very sympathetic one of the
jailers a lieutenant Viet or whose name
ural here in just a minute was kind of
the the high-ranking correctional
officer in charge of the Cubans who were
held there in the jail he actually wrote
a letter to the I NS protesting their
their policies he said they come in here
they do these so-called custody reviews
in which they claim to give these people
a fair shake where where they're not
entitled to have a lawyer by the way and
this correctional officer wrote a letter
to the I NS saying you're not treating
these people right the warden at this
Jail a man named Colonel Bruce lafarge
originally had agreed to let me
interview this particular prisoner who
I'm going to read you a quotation from
in a minute and he then when I got there
changed his mind and I assumed it was a
runaround that I've gotten many times
and I said you know why are you
protecting the i ns if this guy wants to
talk to me he has a right to talk to me
and the warden of this jail said I'm not
protecting the ANS I'm protecting the
prisoner and what the warden was telling
me is that he understood that if this
prisoner said things critical of the is
that the AI NS had the power to
retaliate against him because it's
simply it's a system of unchecked
detention ok I'm not talking about a
particular guard being able to retaliate
that's something that could happen to
any prison any prisoner in any prison
anywhere but here are the people who
decide when you get out could say well
we're not going to let you out now
because we don't like what you said to
that reporter obviously they decided to
let me talk to him after all so I'm
going to read this brief section
he would be the one to talk to
lieutenant Gary Viet or said of hay-soos
anything that happens we look to him for
help hey-soos 44 years old came to the
United States from Cuba in 1980 after
selling drugs to an undercover police
officer he served three and a half years
in an Illinois prison in 1992 he was
convicted of assault on a police officer
and in 1995 he served 20 months in
Florida for violating a restraining
order against his wife in december two
thousand he was taken into I NS custody
yet hey Susie Zion has custody reviews
the immigration officers have asked him
repeatedly about the conviction for
assault on an officer even though the
judge who heard that case gave him no
jail time he was sentenced to a years
probation even the ones that murdered
lieutenant viateur said have done their
time but Cuba does not have to take them
back and the United States does not have
to release them I NS says tough call
Castro he's the one that didn't want you
we don't want you either hay-soos was in
charge of the law library at the
Calcasieu Parish jail in Lake Charles
and he also worked as an interpreter
between detainees and the jail staff
lieutenant via tour was in charge of the
50 or so detainees at the jail he in the
jail's warden had formed i honest
officials that hay-soos could have a job
at the jail after the AI NS released him
but the AI NS still denied hey-soos is
release saying that the answers he gave
during a custody review about his prior
convictions were not quote clear unquote
and that he quote tended to blame others
for his errors lieutenant Viet or felt
the decision was unfair so although I
had called Lake Charles to set up an
interview with someone else Viet or
suggested that I speak with hey-soos I
NS always tells you you've got to watch
those Cubans Viet or volunteer but I
ain't had no trouble and to give hey
Zeus himself the last word and keep in
mind it is it's a man
who's committed crimes as he
acknowledges and at the time I talked to
him he had been detained post serving a
sentence for three years with no end in
sight he was in fact later released hey
sue says we might have criminal
backgrounds we might have broken the law
there are some scumbags in here but
still we are human beings at least we
deserve a chance they're not affecting
only us there's family out there they're
kids mothers wives sisters they're
suffering too they put us in hell this
is hell literal no hope no hope we're
fighting Goliath and God ain't listening
to us this abuse is 20 years old
somebody's got to say something if they
don't want me in this country send me
back if Cuba don't want me back send me
to a jungle I just want to be by myself
free walk around even if I have to hunt
the cockroach raw with my bare hands
I'll manage but don't keep me like
cattle crushing me here not only me
they're crushing all of us I don't know
what else to say let somebody know
somebody's got to care man if you holler
enough this is a big country not all the
people in this country are like I NS I
know look at lieutenant via tour look at
Colonel afar maybe this is even going
against them and they allowing me to
talk to you it's not that everybody's
bad it's just that some bad people are
in charge of i ns there's some officers
here they look at you with hate and you
never even met the guy there's some
small kid a young guy an officer he
means if he catches you in a Cell
handcuffed he's going to beat the dog
out of you for free why he hates I don't
even know the guy why do I NS is like
that I can't understand
all in there and questions anyone want
ask a question or make a comment
i I've been serving as an extra witness
for the past year and a half in about
two dozen different Asylum deportation
hearings my clients are all from the
former Soviet Union mostly Jews and
other ethnic religious minorities
actually yesterday morning helped get
someone out of oakdale prison in
Louisiana so I was really those really
poignant what you read from your book
about that my question is a I've been
pleasantly surprised especially since I
started doing this after nine eleven at
how fair most of the immigration judges
had been at least for me and for my
clients I'm i know it's anecdotal to
understand my own in my own case and i
was wondering how these judges get
selected what sort of pressure can and
has been put on them by the government
to if they've been ruling in favor of
detainees as some of them have what are
the consequences for them if any i have
to tell you it's the second time today
that someone is asked me about
immigration judges which I know
embarrassingly little about considering
the subject of the book that what what I
can tell people so that they understand
is that it's that the immigration judge
that going back before I NS was
dissolved at the immigration judges and
the lawyer opposing the detainee both
worked for the Justice Department so
it's kind of a bizarre pseudo
adversarial system and even so a lot of
judges who won another writer Robert con
who's who's written a terrific book
about detention in the 1980s called
other people's blood he refers to
immigration judges as Bureau as
bureaucrats in judges robes I say that
not to be dismissive but to make it
clear that when we call them judges
they're not article three judges they're
there
even so there are a lot of different
people who are judges in the same way
that I'm saying about correctional
officers and I NS officials themselves
some judges are very fair there's one
eye right in that in the book who has a
very good reputation as far as I know
among lawyers the one of the things that
happened since September 11th though is
that the Attorney General decided that
even though these judges were
technically his employees and there was
a lot of political pressure on them that
he still needed to be careful and so he
promulgated a regulation that allows
basically allows the Immigration Service
to keep someone locked up even if the
immigration judge decides to release
them on bond so as as as one lawyer I
know out in Colorado put it even to
describe this netherworld of immigration
detention as unconstitutional misses the
point she says it's really sub
constitutional so it's I haven't
answered all the elements of your
question but that yes sir yeah it seems
to me that as a physician having some
passing acquaintance with prisons in the
distant past it certainly brings out the
most sadistic I think impulses and
people not only the I NS people but they
often where it's unregulated the guards
especially with people who are helpless
and and further labeled as bad people
yeah but I had some questions about you
mentioned political capital at this
political capital here and I didn't
understand that that's one just a few of
these questions I wondered will the
exposure that that the is the detainees
at Guantanamo and other places are
getting now will that change the
the position of the I NS over time do
you think because it seems to be even
congressional hearings now going in that
direction and I wondered about other
countries and the similarity or
dissimilarity of what we have as opposed
to other and well I can't remember too
many more okay thank you my the third as
far as other countries I don't even want
to try to answer that it's something at
some point in researching the book I
realized I had a lot of questions about
that myself and I don't know enough
about it to really talk to you about it
as far as whether the Guantanamo
decision will will change things I mean
if those decisions as far as I
understand them aren't directly related
to the issues here whether it whether it
will change things in terms of the
atmosphere in terms of of people's
feeling that okay well now we've even
seen a Supreme Court decision say that
people allegedly associates of al-qaeda
can't be held in some netherworld under
us control under yours US jurisdiction
but without access to US courts that was
essentially what the Guantanamo decision
said so that's that's certainly a
positive decision whether in immigration
cases at all levels what the government
is doing all the time is basically
telling the courts to keep their hands
off so so again if there's any
immigration lawyers in the room they
might they might want to add this i'm
not sure if there's a direct link but
it's certainly positive sign but i guess
i have to say i'm not terribly
optimistic and and that goes to to your
first question what I meant by political
capital is that
the Immigration Service to take one
example loves to use the term criminal
alien now you can hardly you could
hardly imagine a less sympathetic
category to be in then being a criminal
being an alien how about both and they
often justify their harsh and repressive
detention policies by using the term
criminal alien in fact I've been to a
couple of Supreme Court arguments in the
last few years on detention issues and
what the Solicitor General or his
deputies like to do is get the phrase
criminal alien in as many times as they
can before the justices start asking
questions what they don't like to
mention is that the phrase criminal
alien can refer to someone who crosses
the Mexican border illegally and goes on
a killing spree which is an example that
they like to use that obviously is
someone who needs to be under some kind
of state custody situation but the term
criminal alien applies equally to that
serial killer and to someone who is here
legally with a green card and jumps a
turnstile or someone who pulls the
mistress of her husband gets into a
fight with the mistress of her husband
and pulls her hair in a fight and is
charged and was born in Germany even
though she house speaks with the Texas
accent because he's been here so long
that's also criminal alien so so when I
talk about political capital I mean that
instead of really facing the lives that
are being torn apart by these laws that
were passed in 1996 I mean tens of
thousands of legal US residents have
been deported for a whole variety of
crimes yes with the conditions you've
outlined in your book for us this
evening are the hands of the US Congress
tide cannot the house of representatives
or the US Senate
take any action or are they prevented by
our new national security measures I
think they're prevented by by national
security propaganda I mean Congress
could could call hearings tomorrow and
look into these allegations you know I'm
not the only one making them there you
know Human Rights reports you know like
this so so the answer is that nothing is
time Congress's hands so hopefully some
of them will step forward and decide to
look into this stuff now now that people
understand that what goes on in prisons
should no longer remain invisible I have
two questions I believe your book came
out if i'm not mistaken shortly before
the prison the rock prison scandal broke
and there was a moment there when the
public I'm impressed was beginning to
make some connections between what went
on there and what goes on in this
country on an everyday basis and also
establishing some concrete flings in
terms of the administrators of US
presidents who had gone to Iraq and
brought with them not only personnel but
also the policies and some of the the
ideology of prison prison culture as
you've outlined it and that window seems
now to be closing somewhat and the focus
is primarily on what went on in Iraq and
not so much on what goes on again here
so my question is what do you think are
the possibilities what what kind of
opportunities do we have for keeping
that window open and continuing to
establish those links in the public
consciousness and the second question is
related to that it concerns the fact
that there is already a significant
amount of literature that's generated
almost two million plus prisoners of
this country most of them in prison for
non non violent offenses and the fact as
the gentleman previously indicated that
these people have no no representation
no no political capital as he might
might have might have said and no
advocacy on their behalf in part because
of the kind of ideological framework
that that they're contained and you know
the language in vocabulary and the
fundamental implication of these people
are other different and therefore not
not worthy of
general civic concern and my question is
do you see any such advocacy efforts
developing beyond the individual lawyers
and organizations that are already
working on that in a larger sense
I think that I think that you're right
that that window opened briefly and
already seems to be closing what like
what I can say is that i know of a lot
of activists who are working with the
families of immigration detainees and
who are also working with other
prisoners families trying to reform drug
laws particularly I live in New York
where the Rockefeller drug laws have
destroyed a lot of people's lives so I
think they're groups working on those
issues I think that people can harangue
their their Congress people and insist
on hearings there may not be any
photographs of what's going on in these
detention centers but as I said there's
there's plenty of documentation I also
think that activists and prisoners
families around the country can go to
the immigration offices in the case of
immigration detainees or it can go
directly to prisons and jails and
detention centers and introduce
themselves as community groups church
groups synagogue groups mosque groups
whatever kind of group it may be and say
we want this prison as part of our
community and we want to monitor what
goes on here and begin a dialogue to set
that up no one is going to hand down a
prison monitoring plan from from on high
a lot of people including myself and
said there should be monitoring but I
think local folks around the country
need to take steps all over the place to
make that happen and and I also just
want to say that the that that
monitoring of what goes on in prisons
and detention centers is beneficial for
the employees at these places as well if
you read some of those Abu Ghraib
stories closely you might remember that
there were officials Milt you know
military guys and women
who were aware of abuses that were going
on and realized that there was no way
they were going to say anything because
there would be retaliation that's that's
without making any any facile
comparisons between Abu Ghraib and
prisons here that is just part of prison
culture so what I'm saying is that I've
met people along the way who work in
immigration or work in prisons who would
also benefit from feeling that they can
behave decently and they're not going to
suffer retaliation themselves for
treating prisoners decently my question
is after 20 years for people who have
been in the United States from different
countries why didn't they get their
citizenship do they have dual
citizenship why aren't they going to
Sudan or to Turkey are they considered
themselves citizens of the world and of
course with Janet Reno what happened to
Gonzalez with families and children but
why didn't they get their citizenship
after 15-20 years it wasn't important I
can't speak for them I can't answer that
I think we have to have a wider idea of
what citizenship is now I was born here
but when I meet somebody from another
country here you know who's been here
for 30 years which is a good percentage
of my life I don't really feel that I
belong here anymore than that person but
as far as why someone you know doesn't
become a citizen you know you have to
ask them
can I respond I'm not us I can hear what
I was six years old I'm 46 now I'm
originates in Chile and fermions that
it's an issue
it's very difficult to camano as i get
older i need to become
take advantage of the benefits that I'm
entitled to but it's also a matter of
principle
during the history of the United States
intervention in my country it's like I
have to it's almost as if I
being a part of myself even though I
feel like I belong here
and what district
you've just outlined some things that
can be done anything else that you'd
like to see happen and upon the national
policy level or media intellectuals I
mean you're doing a lot with the book
but from your point of view what do you
think would be effective well that's uh
it's not an easy question to answer I
mean maybe the best answer I can give is
that I don't think there is one thing
that can be done you know so I think
everybody listening to this you know
we'll have have a different idea of what
to do whether it's somehow to make
stories known whether it's to have
visitation programs for prisoners you
know whether whether its lobbying I mean
there are things that I can't even
possibly think of so I don't really have
an easy answer for you there yeah I mean
listen to you speaking and see the
outrage from your end if you've had a
chance to actually you know talk to
immigrants themselves were in prisons do
you really see a sense of outrage in
them but I mean I'm very I'm an
immigrant I'm from India I expect the
police be brutal i expect the law
enforcement agencies to be well not so
easy going and and i don't think my
expectations are very much I mean that's
where conditioned to if you go to a you
know if you're calling for questioning
there will be some other pressure some
sort of force or something you know it's
part of life do you really see that kind
of conditioning also transfer here that
do you expect a law enforcement
immigration police whatever to be a
little bit on the rough side well I'm
not exactly sure what you're asking me
if at this point for me it's not a
matter of what I expect I mean I've been
watching the Immigration Service for
many years now and and it's a brutal
racist and secretive culture are
immigrants who are detained surprised I
mean some of them might not be but I've
talked to many who are now I've talked
to many who sound more patriotic than
than any American citizens I've ever
talked to because of the expectations
they had and and before coming here and
they're shocked at what was actually
happening to them in these jails so I
mean one of the things I talk about a
little bit in the book is that there are
people there's a Nigerian in particular
who I describe who overstayed his visa
and was you know living his life here
for many years and and he became what in
any other country would be called a
dissident he became a dissonant here
after being locked up by immigration and
being treated in a certain way and he
was outraged yeah
a lot of what you've said underline is
there's a there's a sort of underlying
fact which is that immigrants don't or
aliens don't have the sorts of Rights
that citizens have and in the context of
immigration law they also don't have the
legal framework that non alien criminals
would have right they don't have any
kind of right to counsel as you pointed
out the judges immigration judges are
just administrative judges they don't
they're not article three they don't
there are no nothing like the sorts of
mechanisms of accountability that we
have in our admittedly terribly flawed
criminal justice system there's also an
enormous current in this country and and
very powerful lobbies against immigrants
particularly against criminal aliens in
favor of deportations in favor of
increasing detention there's the whole
national security context after
September 11th there's the Department of
Homeland Security and so on and so forth
in the face of all of that some people
say that that the solution or a solution
would be to criminalize the immigration
law so that a violation of immigration
law would be a crime and in that case at
least people accused of those crimes
would be judged in real courts what do
you think of that i should add one more
one more argument that people make in
favor of this well i'll leave it at that
in other words criminalize illegal entry
criminalized visa overstay is that make
those into essentially turn it from an
administrative law system to a criminal
law system and then detention would also
be subject to real standards again not
not that our criminal law system is any
kind of model to emulate right I don't
underst
like maybe there's a piece on missing it
would just create another layer I mean
if I'm convicted of overstaying my visa
and I serve five years and then I'm
going to be deported then I'm going to
be in AI NS detention right after I
served my son don't know if it were a
crime among other things you'd get a
right to a lawyer and then what would
happen after I served my sentence see
what I mean I don't you would you would
have served the sentence and like any
other criminal you couldn't it like a
like a US citizen criminal you couldn't
be forced to sit in detention beyond the
sentence it doesn't it doesn't solve
those that vitus and beneath the problem
of in people who are in detention
indefinitely because they can't be
deported but that problem isn't solved
by the current system either yeah maybe
we should just take that as something
that you're floating here I'm don't know
that I would have to ask a lot more
questions to understand it better before
I could yeah
anyone else
yes um thank you very much for bringing
that very important information forward
and I want to find out from you whether
there is any positive reaction for
arising from the book you've written
either positive or maybe a reaction that
is negative that is from the people who
normally appreciate this yes the man was
asking me if there's been reaction
either positive or negative to the book
uh there has been you know little little
bits of reaction here and there it's you
know the book hasn't been out that long
so I'm not really sure that I can
generalize in but having said that in
general the reaction I've gotten is that
people are glad to hear about this I
mean they're they're upset about the
details of it but I I found that in
general people are are just surprised
you know people might have known that
there were detentions after September
11th but I find that people are simply
unaware that there's this detention
system so I haven't and I got a very
nice letter from one warden who I
interviewed who told me that he was glad
to see that someone is seeing the whole
picture so that
um yeah coming from him in particular
that that meant a lot so they have not
contacted me directly yet but I think
they know how to get in touch with me
thank you all very much thank you Mark
Dow thank you for coming coming in
tonight to hear this talk the book is
available in the front of store we
encourage you to pick a copy of Mark
will be here to sign copies in the back
so thank you and have a great night
markdown is author of American gulag
it's published by the university of
california press on the web at UC press
dot edu